Probably useful to touch upon the Unreal Engine file structure to give you a little bit more
idea about how the projects are stored and saved.
So to give you a brief overview, Unreal Engine has projects and templates.
Within that you have project files.
Within the project files you have the folders and also the project structure.
So breaking apart each one of these points here.
When we refer to projects and templates we're talking about when you load the launcher and
you want to create a new project, you can see the different series of templates that
we can choose from on the left hand side.
So we can either pick a games based project, film and video based project, architecture
in this instance and then automotive, product design and manufacturing.
So essentially each one of these categories gives you a series of different templates to pick.
Now it actually doesn't matter which project you pick if you want to change.
Unreal Engine can accommodate just because you pick one template doesn't mean that you're
committed to that one specific approach.
However it just pre-builds in some quality of life settings.
It kind of sets all the different features and functionalities you might need with that
given project.
So it's just useful to be able to pick the template from the get go when you're creating your projects.
So when we talk about file saving and copying you have the traditional apps used for a single
project to visualize the scene.
So in this instance we have the piece of software, we click save and we have a file that is created.
So you know when you're working in Photoshop you have PSDs, Word, you have Docs, you may
have made binary files and so you're essentially in the traditional apps.
You have a piece of software and you are saving this file to visualize your scene.
When we talk about UE5 all important assets you know this is models, textures, audio,
anything along those lines are stored in a content folder as UAsset.
So essentially UAsset is just an Unreal Engine asset and it allows you to see things on an
individual basis.
So levels are saved as UMaps which essentially is an Unreal Map and projects are saved as
U projects.
So to give you a better idea about that the project is the main thing that you have created.
It is what stores all the individual assets below that.
So the project is the thing that embodies everything else.
When you create your scenes or levels they are saved as UMaps so they're saved as map
projects.
So all the content is stored separately outside the map for easy access and you can access
them through the map which is inside the project.
So it's kind of a tiered approach there.
So with UE5 we have the level editor, the asset editor, the material editor, just looking
at this diagram here and each one that you save creates a different asset essentially.
So when we talk about aggregating the files in Maya or Photoshop you have FBXs and PNGs.
So these raw data files, the FBXs or the PNGs, they will then get transferred into a UAsset,
so an Unreal Asset.
So instead of using the raw naming convention then everything gets turned into a UAsset.
So when we look at the project folder structure generally you'll see these folders.
If you have a C++ engine version or anything like this you might see a few extra folders
in your file structure but these are the main folders to look for when creating your project.
So wherever you decide to store your projects maybe the defaults of the documents in Unreal
Projects sorry but essentially we've got the config folder here at the top which is,
houses all your configurations for the project.
So any kind of inputs or different post process settings maybe that you've saved, anything
that you've configured for that specific project are in the config folder.
The content is where all of these UAssets get stored which we were referring to before
whether a UAsset or maps and assets are stored in your content.
So essentially any content that you can edit at real time is in your content folder.
Intermediate and saved are more of the cached folders so intermediate just saves a bunch
of information that lets your engine run a bit faster and then saved if you have any
auto saves or maybe you've saved some screenshots in the engine, maybe you've saved some movie
exports that will generally all go into saved.
And then your UProject which is the blue icon is what you would load to load up the larger
project.
It's quite a small file size and that houses all of the folders above it.
We can access them through the UProject.
So to give you a little bit of a better idea about that you know the project encases everything
else the project is this holistic thing that holds all the information.
You will create levels within the project so that you can access through the editor
window and then each of these levels will have some form of actors which are these UAssets
inside of Unreal Engine that you can use to create the content that you desire.